ich hatte hier in der mitte ein
hakenkreuz zum beispiel wo sich das ich
sehe mich selber nicht jährlich eine
halbe kreuz in der mitte tätowiert und
das habe ich schon 2008 über gestochen
2015 das sich aber auch genauso für mich
ist heute ein arschloch unabhängig von
der hautfarbe oder von der region ja ein
arschloch ist ein arschloch und schweden
aus deutschland kommende davon machen es
nicht mehr auch wenn die für ein scheiß
[ __ ] scheiß charakter
[Musik]
rassismus ist für mich eigentlich eine
idee einer gesellschaft und es ist eine
und mein name ist philipp schlager ich
bin 40 jahre alt geworden dieses jahr
kommen aus lübeck jetzt wieder wohnhaft
bei lübeck ich selber war über 15 jahre
in der rechtsextremen szene und danach
und noch sechs jahre im rotlicht milieu
und auch in der rocker szene was das
eine ganz kurze zusammenfassung meine
person
ich bin an die nato berlin ich bin 26
jahre alt kommen aus schleswig holstein
eigentlich wurde in hamburg keine derby
zwischen hamburg und berlin
die moderatorin eigentlich
moderedakteurin ich bin ein schausteller
kind die schausteller familie
aufgewachsen und bin quasi durch
schleswig-holstein und hamburg gereist
und weil jede woche einer mann an bord
also meine wurzeln bedeutet mir sehr
viel weil ich das ja komplett aus macht
und weil ich mich auch damit
beschäftigen muss also selbst werde ich
das gar nicht wollte könnte ich nicht
sagen das ist nicht so also es macht
mich zu 100 prozent aus
ich hätte vorgenommen hier ist er jetzt
einmal nach gambia zu fliegen wo meine
familie dort zu besuchen
seine afrikanischen gene sind nämlich
genauso wie meine leute deutsch geben
ich denke gar nicht so viel darüber nach
ist das einfach so ich bin stolz drauf
und ist toll und will es unbedingt
einbrechen
herzlich willkommen zum samstag war
video heute zeige ich euch wie ich
diesen turm an hinbekommen habe es war
eine sehr schwere geburt aber von einem
konzert mit in die outtakes dann mache
ich das jetzt nach hinten rüber seht ihr
das dreiecks spitze die drei spezies
vorne
ich nehme die beiden enden weil sie ein
bisschen ein steckt man habe darauf dass
sie drin sind
dann einmal tristen und hinten einfach
einstecken dauert zwei sekunden fertig
worum geht's hier rechtlich rocker ja
das ist jetzt kein kanal wo werbung
gemacht wird für rechtsextreme oder
ludwig motiv sind oder in der
kriminellen szene drogenhandel und so
weiter sondern ich nutze diesen block i
bei youtube oder bei facebook instagram
und so weiter wolle mich überall findet
nutze ich um meine erfahrungen dazu
geben welche erfahrung ich in dieses hin
gemacht habe mit den menschen wie die
mechanismen sind wie das funktioniert
wie man da rein getrickst wird was man
da erlebt um mir gefällt will muss ich
doch verhelfen das junge mädchen junge
frauen da nicht rein kommen junge männer
da nicht ran kommt dass diese linken
lebensweg nicht gegen den ich gegangen
bin
denn und zwar im gefängnis geändert ist
ich habe sehr viele opfer gebracht auf
diesem weg ich habe mich selber
verfahren auch meine familie zum opfer
gemacht und so weiter zehn jahre alt war
haben meine eltern mir und meiner
schwester eröffnet dass wir nach england
ziehen nach newcastle upon tyne und das
war was wollte ich unbedingt ich war
zehn jahre alt und dann bin so mobbing
los so wie alle deutschen sind nazis
das habe ich zu hause gehört und dass
wir haben gegen die kriege führt und die
auf england bombardiert und so weiter
und dann ging massives mobbing loos bis
hin zu schlagen spucken ausgrenzung und
so weiter ich habe natürlich auch nicht
gewusst warum ich selber hatte mit dem
thema nazi noch überhaupt keinen kontakt
gehabt zu dem zeitpunkt
ich habe mich dann halt auch körperlich
gewährt noch da auch das erste mal
gemerkt na gut das kann ja auch ganz gut
funktionieren wenn man sondern auch mal
zurückschlägt und nach dreieinhalb
jahren jetzt knapp 13 einhalb 14 jahre
haben meine eltern mir meine schwester
wie er verkündet wir zurück nach
deutschland
ich war jetzt wieder auf einer schule
hatte das außenseiter gefühl ja ich
hatte frustig hatte wut und bin dann in
kontakt gekommen aber darüber die schule
über musik über andere jungs die auch
ähnlich fühlten und dann auch
dementsprechend diese musik gehört haben
wenn jemand nicht viel im leben hat weil
er im leben auch benachteiligt wurde
auch das muss man ganz klar sagen es
gibt benachteiligte menschen auch in
diesem land und da kommt jemand um die
ecke und sagt auf einmal
du wirst nur gut alleine dass du hier
geworden bist das tut auch mal gut zu
hören
und daran kann niemand wachsen und das
wissen diese leute da oben dass einige
menschen das einfach hören wollen du
bist gut einfach nur dass du geboren
bist in diesem land allein aus haben
heute gibt es ein video wo wir zum thema
ko phase
ich sage euch die produkte die ich bei
curling shops gekauft der habe ich im
körper richtig chef bekommen
ich zeige euch die wie ich die anwende
verwende wie ich die finde und ja also
mir war ja bewusst als ich mit youtube
angefangen habt dass es eigentlich kaum
afrodeutsche youtuber gab oder kein
glaube ich eine person und ich wusste
dass es wichtig ist dass wir da sind
aber ich hab mir nicht als ziel gesetzt
dass ich jetzt das bin was was was ich
jetzt bin oder das sollte mir eines
tages so nachrichten schreiben
wir wollen die meinung von mir hören
weil ich dadurch die den eventuell
präsentiere und sagen auch du kannst du
zu was sagen weil du bist die person die
es anspricht
deshalb erwarten leute aus von mir dass
ich mich zu themen äußern was ich auch
gerne machen leute
das nehme ich auch noch viel mehr im
video ich war ja ein bisschen krank
angeschlagen der stimme auf und ihr seht
kann man das überhaupt sehen das ist so
ich bin heute nicht in deutschland
unterwegs ich für den birmingham ich
finde hier mit einem projekt europäische
union und bin hier mit anderen mit
anderen die sich um das thema
radikalisierung kümmern
man fängt erst an und sagt ja pro
deutschland dann ultra deutsch und dann
kommt so rassismus hat man so ja nicht
so viele flüchtlinge nicht so viele
ausländer und dann ja aber das ist auch
nicht so gut dass in jeder ecke in den
anlagen ist also es so eine steigerung
man wird immer radikaler man merkt dass
selber gar nicht also man steigert sich
da hinein und das ist ein prozess über
monate oder über jahre und wir müssen
heute da ein bisschen unterscheiden
zwischen dieser dieser gewalttätigen
szene die es gibt sie die
rechtsextremistische szene und zwischen
der neuen rechten die neue rechte greift
das thema natürlich auch und sagt wir
sind keine rassisten aber bitte alle
ethnien sollen dahin gehen wo sie
herkommen ja also sagen sie sind keine
rassisten sondern sie sprechen immer von
kultur ja also sie werden nicht auf
äußerliche merkmale jemanden öffentlich
reduzieren
für mich ist es wahnsinnig schlimm zu
sehen dass die rechte seite so viel
zuspruch bekommt das tatsächlich leute
im bundestag sitzen die einfach da nicht
hingehören
ganz offensichtlich nicht und trotzdem
da sind das ist für mich eigentlich
unerklärlich meiner szene ende ich ja
tiefer wo es ganz offensiv darum ging
was muss auch auszuleben war es nachher
so dass es sehr schnell auch in
körperliche angriffe gegangen ist das
öffentlich das gesagt worden ist dass
jemand auch gesagt hat ich würde zum
beispiel sagen also wenn man mit den
kameraden an so einem supermarkt waren
die man hat den einkaufswagen vorher von
uns an
fast von jemandem andersfarbig hat man
die einkaufswagen dann nicht mehr
angefasst und so nah oder wenn der in
den äpfeln herumgewühlt hat man gesagt
den apfel wegen dessen beschimpfungen
gab es auf jeden fall schon oder einfach
letzteres in berlin in charlottenburg
ist die bahn uns vorbeigelaufen
scheiß ausländer ruft einfach weil er
sauer ist wahrscheinlich ich weiß es
nicht aber das sind so beschimpfungen
die ich weiß ja nicht ob die mich sehr
verletzen aber die machen mich eher
wütend also ich wäre sehr sauer und ich
habe jetzt angefangen andere leute
anzuzeigen zeigt jetzt an daran an
jetzt hat mir jemand auf inseln
geschrieben dies sollte baumwolle
pflücken gehen und aber 18 oder so oder
ist das krass wenn ihr ein 18-jähriger
mir schreibt und ausbauen so lief
stücken gehen soll kommt das denn
eigentlich kann mir gar nicht von sich
aus sagen die baumwolle pflegen musste
sie ja beigebracht dass im museum
gehören
als erstes werde ich meine haare zu
waschen dafür nehme ich ein so fad
freies schampus und wandelt er macht aus
diesen beiden produkten jetzt mein
conditioner fertig einmal hier kokosöl
also das mache ich nach dem waschen denn
die noch feuchte macht es da rein aber
nicht so sollen die habe öffentlich und
für jene leute mit migrationshintergrund
oder anders aussehende leute also
vermeintlich anders aussehende leute
erleben hat tagtäglich rassismus
rassismus beginnt ja schon wenn ich im
drogeriemarkt gehe und ich finde nichts
für meine hautfarbe oder für meine haare
gibt es nicht als würden einfach nur
weiße menschen existieren in deutschland
war schwachsinn ist wenn man auf die
straße geht sieht man die vielfalt
rädern in drogeriemarkt sich cal halt
lockiges haar grünes haarspray und das
hat alles aber kein affront
das ist für mich auch schon rassismus
ich werde ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
ich bin nicht am anfang ein gekommen
dass ich aufgewacht bin war neonazi
sondern da habe ich mich hin gearbeitet
nach mehreren jahren genau so arbeitet
man sich von diesem punkt des neonazis
runter so dass nationalsozialisten der
diese politische idee umsetzen möchte
wandelt man sich genau so langsam da
auch wieder runter mit zwei oder drei
anderen aus dem club in einer anderen
rocker club eingetreten
ich war die zu diesem zeitpunkt schon
auch tätigt im rotlichtmilieu verstrickt
auch schon andere kriminelle aktivitäten
und die lassen sich teilweise ja auch
nicht mehr vereinbaren mit einem
gewissen nationalsozialistischen
weltbild dann hier am 20.7 wurde auch
die schaufensterscheibe selbigen ob
jetzt der ezb in rostock mit einer
scharfen schusswaffe mehrfach geschossen
aufgrund der offenkundigen zusammenhänge
der sachverhalte wurden ermittlungen
gegen philip kalisch lacher unklar
bleibt ob die staatsanwaltschaft rostock
geführt
ja das ist viermal so ein bild so
aussieht zeit so ungefähr mit manchmal
so sieht wie wir was für ein
sympathischer junger waren also ich
selber ich finde das ist fürchterlich
wenn ich mich so sehr eine meiner ersten
interkulturellen begegnung war ja mit
kriminellen ausländern
für uns war das war ganz komisch waren
als rocker club und hat eine anderen
andere clubs zu besuch und da gab es da
gab es wodka ob sie waren halt fast nur
mit personen mit migrationshintergrund
und die korruptions zu besuch und die
haben immer ganz scherzhaft so gesagt ja
das sind hier unsere nazis aus dem osten
um junge gesagt das sind unsere [ __ ]
aus dem westen so komisch das jetzt zu
klingen hat man sich auch einmal ganz
gut verstanden
man hat sich da der übergeordneten sache
also dem geld verdienen das stand dann
oberste priorität geld und macht hat man
seinen persönlichen ressentiments
zurückgesetzt oder gesagt okay lass uns
wollen wir den treffen das thema
kennenlernen und dann war es super
nachdem man die kennengelernt hat mir so
gedacht ja landbrücke ja so ein weltbild
für mich ist heute ein arschloch
unabhängig von der hautfarbe oder von
der religion ja wäre ein arschloch ist
das scheißegal ob er das schweden aus
deutschland kommt wieder aus südafrika
oder aus china und davon mache ich nicht
mehr abhängig wären scheiß charakter
hatten scheiß charakter man musste man
aufpassen dass eine bevölkerung ein
thema nicht zu viel wird ja also ich
kann jetzt über meine familie sprechen
schön meine eltern jetzt nicht wissen
aber meine eltern braucht man mit mitte
70 nicht mehr erklären dass sie nicht
[ __ ] kurs sagen dürfen was kriegen
meine eltern die sagen die meinen ist
auch nicht was ich will jetzt auch keine
diskussionen losdrehen schüler die
sollten das lernen aber meine eltern
wenn die das vorgehalten kriegen die
sondern also lassen sie mich jetzt in
ruhe damit und dann treibt man die erst
recht in diese ecke ich würde es viele
wichtige finden dass wir demokratie
wertevermittlung ja also dass sie dass
wir die gleichheit der menschen und
demokratische werte vermitteln das ist
mir ein wichtiges anliegen und dann
abgelegt nur wieder an erwachsene
reduziere jugendlichen nicht darauf dass
sie vielleicht mal die schule
abgebrochen haben dass sie in motzen
fünf fragen oder dass sie mal ein bus
halten und dort an bier trinken oder mal
einen joint
lasst den jungen leuten raum gebt ihnen
wertschätzung nimmt sie mit auf die
reise weil wenn er es nicht macht kommt
irgendjemand im internet um die ecke und
sagt diesen jungen leuten du bist gut so
wie du bist und möchtest du richtig
stark und anerkannt werden dann kommen
noch mal uns besuchen und das machen
kriminelle gleich wie extremisten und
deswegen sollte vorher darauf geachtet
werden dass erwachsene einfach
jugendlichen einfach mal wertschätzung
geben zu hören für deren probleme für
deren brüche und dann werden
extremistische szene und krimis 10
weniger zulauf
ihr werdet ihr zum kuscheln mit seinem
bruder freut mich gucken wir was für
eine dieser tennis
[Musik]